So there's a white nationalist, Richard Spencer,
who I've actually interviewed on the program
and I encourage you to check that interview
out.
He's considered in some sense the founder
of the outright, but he's definitely a white
nationalist.
He said that that is inappropriate term among
others to be using for him.
When I interviewed him on the show a couple
of years ago and Spencer has now been, they're
calling it outage, but I don't actually know
that that's the right term.
He's been quote outed by an audio tape where
he uses all of the angry vitriolic slurs that
many white nationalists use about Jews and
about black people.
Now you might be saying, well, why is it notable
that a white nationalist was using those terms
about Jews and black people?
And the reason it's notable is precisely because
Richard Spencer's entire thing was, yes, he's
a white nationalist.
Yes, he wants a, a white ethno state where
everyone who is not as he calls it of European
origin, uh, leaves the country, but he's an
educated, articulate, elegant, well-dressed
guy who wants those things and he wants those
things to happen respectfully or something.
I mean within the context of how, how respectfully
can you have a an athlete and ethnic cleansing,
right?
But the idea is he doesn't scream at people.
He doesn't use racial slurs.
He wants it all to be peaceful and for everybody
to agree that races are going to separate.
Now all along, and this is why I say that
the term outed is maybe a bit of an exaggeration.
Anyone with any common sense probably guessed
that behind closed doors, Richard Spencer
was just your normal, average white supremacist
racist, but he was able to kind of keep up
the facade for some time.
He would couch his views in history or sociology
or science as they claim now to be doing in
a very popular and sometimes unfortunately
effective way.
But this is now all imploded.
So it just so happens that the person who
released this audio tape is another right
wing bomb thrower named Milo Yiannopoulos
who I actually emailed with about six or eight
weeks ago.
It didn't go well, that email exchange, the
emails had nothing to do with this.
Milo has released the recording.
It's bad.
We're going to listen to it.
Now.
Nothing surprising about this in some superficial
sense.
This does contain shocking language.
So probably best as they say to a get the
kids out of the room.
We're coming back here like a hundred times.
I am so mad daddy.
These I am coming back here every weekend
by am to like, this is never over.
I think that's how the world works.
They get rules.
I people like me, we're the rule, the rule
by people like me look up and see your face.
Looking down at them, we are going to destroy
this town.
So of course you know, talking about kikes
and octoroons slurs for Jews and black people.
So there's really only one takeaway here.
Actually.
I actually think that the analysis here is
a pretty simple one.
Richard Spencer is just like all the people
that he claims to be different from, right.
He says he's not some lowbrow racist, he's
not some of abrasive, uneducated yokel or
whatever.
Right?
Because he's the dapper white nationalist.
Well, this sounds just like anybody else that
you would imagine white nationalists would
be in cahoots with.
He plays the polite, well dressed white nationalist
who uses coded, but arguably less threatening
sounding terms like peaceful ethnic cleansing,
a Kindler, gentler sort of white nationalism,
but it's all the same stuff.
Now, why did Milo Yiannopoulos publish this?
He says quote, as for why I published it,
I have always publicly hated Spencer and he
has always publicly hated me.
He thinks I'm a degenerate race mixing kike
and I think he's a knuckle dragging racist
in a cheap suit.
As you will recall, he was paid to sneak into
a bar.
I was singing karaoke in and throw up Nazi
salutes and film it without my knowledge.
So it has been very satisfying for me to draw
a crisp, bright red line between the two of
us.
So there it is.
It's just different factions of the vial,
right?
In this case, they are clashing with each
other, Milo and Richard Spencer.
But the lesson is you've got to pay attention
to the substance and not the tone.
Because if you go back to the interview that
I did with Spencer, I believe it was back
in 2017 or you look at anything that he's
done, if you listened only to the substance
of Spencer for the last however many years,
this would not be even remotely surprising
to you.
You might still be taken aback by the crass
nature of the language.
Sure.
But the substance would not be even remotely
surprising.
The people who were surprised by this had
sort of been lulled by the tone and the optics
of Richard Spencer, and they weren't paying
attention to the substance.
That was a bad decision all along.
Uh, and this is just confirmation of that.
Nothing new, nothing unusual we haven't heard
before.
Just surprising some people because they understood
Richard Spencer to be more of a quote, academic
educated white nationalist.
Nothing in you here.
And we'll see if anything develops as far
as the release of the actual tape and Milo
Yiannopoulos, his involvement, although it
may be, you know, another one of Milo's attempts
to reinserted himself into the political dialogue,
uh, at least within some enclaves of the internet
after he was essentially completely pushed
out after comments about, I'm trying to remember,
is it technically pedophilia or was it hemophilia?
Now I don't remember in any case comments
that were poorly, they were not well received
even by, uh, many of the factions of the right
that had previously embraced Milo.